let's get reaction tonight from
Democratic National Committee chairman
Tom Perez mr. chairman thanks for being
here always a pleasure to brown you hurt
speaker Ryan they're talking about this
race and his take from it your reaction
to that and what do you take from this
race even the Republicans are contesting
you know to say that they they may still
win well I think this race is over mr.
ciccone can contest it but I think it's
gonna be pretty clear that kind of lamps
gonna be the next member of Congress
from that district and you know what I
hear
speaker Ryan talk about that here's the
reality the number one issue was health
care in the district Democrats believe
that health care is our right for all
not a privilege for a few and we've seen
the repeated efforts to make it harder
for people struggling with the opioid
addiction to get access to health care
the health care voter came out and
forced and they were supporting Connor
Lam similarly there's a lot of folks
there who are mine workers who are
losing their pensions they've been
fighting for them and the Republican
Party hasn't been doing a darn thing for
him and so Democrats in Connor Lam was
we he was fighting for the right to
organize fighting to make sure that
people had a good wage and pension
security he was fighting in short for
issues that are core to the Democratic
Party and that's why he won are there
enough Connor Lambs to win conservative
districts like this in the midterms
ahead like you did in 2006 oh I think so
and and you look you look around right
now there are 118 districts that are
actually more competitive than the
district that was won yesterday and this
Senator flake correctly said it was a
20-point margin for Donald Trump so if
I'm a Republican I'm very worried right
now because Democrats that the Democrats
are fired up we're fielding good
candidates that's a big lesson from this
and we're organizing everywhere and and
we're talking about the issues that
people care the most about
so if Democrats win the house is Nancy
Pelosi the speaker that'll be up to the
Democrats but don't these candidates
like Connor Lam who ran away from Nancy
Pelosi have to say that they wouldn't
vote for her well that's exactly what
Connor Lam said that's correct but you
know here's the thing about the
the 18th district election that when
your only when your only argument and
this is what it came down to for Connor
lambs opponent is he's going to support
Nancy Pelosi which he said he wasn't
that is a weak argument what voters want
to know in Pennsylvania is are you gonna
help fight for health care are you gonna
help fight for my pension security are
you gonna help fight for for good jobs
and and they heard nothing from the
Republican candidate they had no message
and we were talking about those
bread-and-butter issues this is I mean
there's no doubt about it this was a big
moment for Democrats in this district
why is the DNC having a tough time
fundraising oh we we had we raised more
money last year breath in 2015 2013 and
and when I came in we were basically
shut down as you know I didn't get there
till roughly the 1st of March yeah I
mean if you look at January though
compared to the RNC you've got total
raise six point one to twelve point four
what you've spent what's what your debt
is 5.6 million to zero for the RNC and
if you look at 2017 just comparing the
two there's a lot a lot of difference
between the DNC and the Orang see why is
the question because the RNC has richer
donors we raise money from the
grassroots in 2005 Brett the RNC out
raised the DNC two-to-one same thing
happened last year in 2006 we won the
house in 2008 we won the White House
we've been winning elections over the
course of 2017 this is not an aberration
this is a trend and I think we're
winning because frankly while the
Republican National Committee out raises
us they're morally bankrupt they're
investing in the likes of Roy Moore in
Alabama they had to put millions of
dollars into this race yesterday the joe
arpaio in arizona when you filled
candidates who are so weak and and and
now they're gonna spend a lot of money
on the Trump Legal Defense Fund
meanwhile we're spending money on
organizing it I'd rather spend money on
organizers how do you square the circle
about Democrats like Connor Lam who are
different than where the party overall
is headed for exam
are there is the umbrella bigger in the
Democratic Party for pro-life democrats
you you once said that that they warrant
but is it now that that's not an
accurate statement and and here's here's
the thing here's what i learned in
politics early on you know there when i
talk about unity we should never confuse
unity with unanimity i'm not saying that
everybody has to agree with me I'm proud
of the platform of the Democratic Party
but I respect the fact that people have
honest differences of opinion on issues
of importance and I'm gonna be working
hard to get Bob Casey reelected that
Connor Lam elected and re-elected and I
guess the 17th district now has its real
serve as its redistricting and that's
the beauty of the Democratic Party
Connor Lam was able to speak to those
issues that folks cared about so who's
the leader of the Democratic Party well
I think there are many leaders of the
Democratic Party I think those young
people today who were marching all over
this country are incredible leaders I
think women who've been leading the
resistance have been remarkable leaders
and I think there are there are mayors
governors folks here in Congress that's
why I'm so excited about where we're
going one of those Oaks really one of
those women spoke out in India over the
weekend Hillary Clinton saying that she
won places that are optimistic diverse
dynamic moving forward and Trump's whole
campaign make America great again was
looking backwards you know you didn't
like black people getting rights you
don't like women getting jobs you don't
like to see what Indian Americans
succeeding more that you are whatever
your problem is I'm going to solve it
and she went on to say that essentially
all of a sudden white women were going
who were going to vote for me and
frankly standing up to the men in their
lives and the men in the workplaces were
being told she's going to jail you don't
want to vote for her so wit men were
telling women how to vote do you agree
with Hillary Clinton and how she phrased
this election 2016 well you know I
Donald Trump is the president United
States although Hillary Clinton won the
majority she won more votes than Donald
Trump and you know what not how I have
they tally it for the presidency but
understand the electoral college she won
the popular vote
I accept that he is the president of the
States and what we've been doing is
looking forward to make sure we learn
from our mistakes of the past and one of
them our mistakes is we need to organize
everywhere we need to clearly articulate
what we stand for that's exactly what
happened in Pennsylvania with Connor
lamb he was talking about those bread
and butter issues that nipple care yeah
I think Connor lamb would invite Hillary
Clinton to campaign for him do you well
you know we didn't even feel the
candidate in their district last time
and that was a [ __ ] about us moment the
last two cycles Brett we were infield in
the candidate and you know what
we lost district 18 the margin was
something like seventy thousand votes
which exceeded the entire margin in the
state of Pennsylvania that was a shame
on us moment as Democrats that's why
we're flooding the zone now
fielding great candidates everywhere so
that we can compete everywhere because I
think our message resonates everywhere
we'll see if Hillary Clinton is a
surrogate in the midterms
mr. chairman we appreciate your time and
thanks for comments a pleasure to be
with you Brett